je vais commencer ce talk par une idée
l'idée d'un de mes mentors qui s'appelle
jacques brel un mais deux mentors
spirituelle parce qu'évidemment je n'ai
pas connu par contre son idée je la
trouve vraiment génial c'est que pour
lui l'homme l'homme avec un grand h
construit sa vie autour de ses rêves
pour jacques brel jusqu'à 20 ans tout
homme chacun d'entre eux ou ce même mois
on a tous des rêves jusqu'à 20 ans à
partir de 20 ans notre vie est finie
entre guillemets on a construit toute
notre personnalité et ensuite chaque
homme va passer sa vie de 20 ans jusqu'à
sa mort a réalisé l'ensemble de ses
rêves je m'appelle alexandre rochon et
je vais vous partagez les trois grosses
claques que j'ai eu ces deux dernières
années qui m'ont permis de bouleverser
ma vie en 2016 le 6 décembre 2016
j'ai tout juste 26 ans je suis ingénieur
travaux dans la grande distribution en
tant que maître d'ouvragé
tout va bien j'ai un cdi chez un emploi
stable d'une mutuelle la vie coule est
en fait un moment donné ce mardi là je
vais sur un chantier sur une opération
qui était en cours de fin de chantier on
devait livrer le bâtiment au bout de
deux semaines est en fait j'apprends
lors de la réunion de chantier qu'on
devait décaler l'opération décalée d'une
semaine et dans la grande distribution
décalé une opé d'une semaine c'est
retarder l'ouverture du magasin d'une
semaine est une semaine
c'est une semaine de chiffre d'affaires
se fait beaucoup beaucoup d'argent donc
j'ai derrière moi j'avais une pression
de dingue et à partir de là premier
réflexe j'appelle mon boss françois je
l'appelle je lui explique la situation
je dis qu'on doit décaler le truc et là
il me dit en 10 secondes bouge pas
j'arrive on déjeune ensemble
ok ça durait du reste à ce moment là
j'ai qu'une chose en tête
j'ai besoin de soutien j'ai besoin d'un
patron qui met paul et qu'il me dise ok
alex on a trouvé des solutions
ok alex on va supporter le point
ensemble pour le donner à la hiérarchie
l'information n'est en fait ce déjeuner
s'étoffe
c'était fou mais on a passé une heure je
me suis fait démonter je me suis fait
démonter par mon propre boss pour qui
j'avais énormément d'admiration
pourquoi parce que lui aussi il avait de
la pression derrière et lui je lui en
rajoute et un peu plus est en fait après
ce déjeuner je suis rentré au bureau je
me suis assis j'ai vu une pile énorme de
dossiers sur lesquels y avait des post
it et la marque est urgent à faire a
signé ensuite jour mon ordinateur je
vois j'ai trois cent cinquante mille à
traiter
on est le mardi c'est le début de la
semaine je suis content ça ça a été ma
première claque
la première claque c'est de me rendre
compte qu'en fait je faisais un boulot
qui était génial mais au bout d'un
certain temps où j'étais sous l'eau à ce
moment là devant mon bureau j'ai pris ma
tête je les mises entre eux mais demain
comme ça je me rappelle très bien j'ai
eu un blackout ce black out
en fait je me suis effondré j'ai eu des
larmes
j'étais pas vraiment pas bien j'étais
vraiment dans le mal on peut appeler ça
un burn-out
on peut l'appeler comme on veut mais en
gros ce truc qui c'est arrivé ça m'a
permis de me poser plein de questions
les questions je me suis posée c'est ok
qu'est ce que tu fais là en fait qu'est
ce que tu vas faire ta vie est ce que là
où tu es est ce que ça te plait ça ça a
été ma première claque jamais cette
image parce que quand on regarde ce
google tu tapes claque tu tombe
directement là dessus et on a tous pris
des faits c'est d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment pas mal ça il ya des il ya
plein de gens qui parlent de la fessée
etc
mais je pense que des claques ça fait
vraiment du bien et je remercie mon père
à l'âge de 5 ans qui m'a donné la plus
grosse fessée de ma vie parce que je
voulais pas dire merci à une serveuse
qui m'apporte un jus d'orange et avec
tout l'amour de mon père ça devait être
très difficile de me lie à ce point là
de me donner une fessée
bref je pensais donc la première claque
c'est de se rendre compte qu'on vit nos
vies et qui ne nous plaît pas juste
après ça j'en vois un texto à un ami mon
meilleur ami thomas on s'est connus en
prépa en 2009
on s'est connus en prépa avec thomas et
là on s'appelle il dit ok ça va mal
viens on va boire un coup comme entre
potes on boit des coups on se retrouve
dans un bar on commande une pente et là
on commence à discuter comme d'habitude
comme à chaque fois on refait le monde
il me raconte ses rêves il me raconte
que lui aussi lent peu plus et qu'il a
envie de faire qu'une seule chose c'est
de servir plus grands thomas lui c'est
un génie de l'informatique
on a fait près pas tous les deux mois je
partis dans le béton lui les partis dans
l'informatique et aujourd'hui c'est un
super génie il parle de ses rêves il dit
l'an prochain en 2010 7 g faire un
million d'euros c'est quand tu vas faire
tu fais combien cette année je fais
quarante 40 kg au hockey et quand tu vas
faire je ne sais rien bon on avance
et là il me dit j'ai envie de servir
plus grand de créer une boîte qui
cartonne de faire une pépite
et à ce moment là il reçoit un sms prend
son téléphone
ils y sont et c'est messi répond jusque
là tout va bien et moi j'étais de
l'autre côté et je vois derrière son
téléphone un moment qui m'a énormément
marqué derrière son téléphone il avait
écrit à la main sur un post it un
million d'euros et là je le dis mais
qu'est ce que tu es en train de faire
c'est que ces causes des vertus été
complètement taré et là il me dit alex
j'ai compris une chose si tu poses ton
intention sur ton objectif est que temps
rappelle tous les jours ne cherche pas à
comprendre ton conscient et inconscient
faty à mener sont conscients et
inconscients vaty a mené du court lui il
a tout compris vu qu'il utilise son
téléphone toute la journée il a mis 1
millions derrière et à chaque fois qu'il
utilise son téléphone il se rappelle jeu
les mêmes chez lui juste derrière il
avait foutu d 1 million partout sur les
interrupteurs à post-it par ci devant
les toilettes un post it
au moins il était obligé de le voir et
ça c'est important si vous avez un
objectif poser le partout et relisez le
ça c'était ma première claque et en
voyant mon ami mon pote parler de ses
rêves je me suis dit mais merde ils sont
mes rêves
ils sont les liens voix avant 20 ans je
rêvais d'être pilote je rêvais de
voyager de découvrir le monde est en
fait je me suis rendu compte que jusqu'à
20 ans j'arrivais à réaliser mes rêves
en seconde je me rappelle j'avais bossé
dans un club de planeur gratuitement et
en échange et une forme et à 16 ans j'ai
eu mon brevet de planeur j'avais
accompli mon rêve d'être pilote
je voulais être pianiste je me suis mis
au piano à 8 ans je voulais faire des
voyages avec mes parents j'ai voyagé
avec mes potes à l'école je voyageais
aussi enfin du coup jusqu'à cet âge là
j'y arrive et ensuite j'ai eu mon
premier job mon premier cdi
hélas après je suis rentré dans une
routine pourquoi parce que le métier
passionnant on vit plein de choses on
vit plein de trucs on est à fond dans
notre job mais en fait avec du recul à
bosser 70 heures par semaine je me suis
un peu oublié et être avec mon associé
aujourd'hui qui est thomas de me rendre
compte que j'avais oublié mes rêves ça
ça m'a fait très mal ça a été ma
deuxième claque avec lui là je sais pas
si vous connaissez c'est un screen que
j'ai fait sur youtube
c'est une vidéo qui s'appelle j'ai vomi
dans mes cordes flex c'est un nom assez
atypique je vous incite à la regarder
c'est pas mal en fait le fait d'oublier
ses rêves c'est pas grave et c'est pour
ça que je viens ici parler avec vous
c'est en fait c'est se rendre compte
qu'on a oublié ses rêveurs avec cette
claque en voyant thomas qui me
rappellent qu'ils m'auraient fait un
petit rappel à l'ordre
ça m'a permis de comprendre que j'étais
en train de les oublier et à 26 ans a
oublié ses rêves ça va il nous reste
encore un peu de marge pour les réaliser
donc en fait ce qu'on a pu faire c'est
de se dire ok toi tu veux monter une
boîte moi aussi je veux monter une boîte
je rêvais d'être entrepreneur quand
j'étais gamin je pour un petit pour la
petite histoire quand j'étais au collège
à l'époque je peux dans quelques années
c'était c'était le modem 56k pas si vous
avez connu ça c'est le modem qui nous
relie à internet qui coupait le
téléphone
donc évidemment comme quelqu'un de
connecté à la maison recevez plus le
téléphone c'était c'était un peu la cata
et en fait à l'époque je commandais sur
e-bay des petits clés usb des clés mp3
c'était l'ancêtre de l'ipod et j'en
passe et je revendais ça le double à mes
copains au collège pareil quand je
faisais des voyages en classe en italie
où avec la classe il y avait toujours
des mecs dans la rue qui vendait des
petits lasers ce genre de truc est en
fait ces mecs je leur négocier je leur
en acheter 10 15 à prix de gros
je les achetais j'allais au collège les
revendre et de folle prix moi je m'amuse
avec mon laser les gars il est trop bien
et c'est maintien je te le vent je le
vendais de folie et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les lasers
s'ajuste des piles du coup j'étais les
piles et je leur rendais donc c'était
l'intérêt de faire du business et de
faire l'achat revente ça me plaisait et
c'était ça mon rêve
donc après avoir fait ingérer pendant
trois ans quatre ans en maîtrise
d'ouvragé dans le métier dans lequel je
m'éclate et vraiment je me suis rappelé
de ses rêves d'entreprendre et avec
thomas on a décidé en janvier 2010 est
donc assez rapidement qu'on allait faire
quelque chose ensemble
on était deux potes en prépa en 2009 on
avait comme beaucoup de gens préparent
un peu de pression vis-à-vis des
concours et pour s'évader un petit peu
on se mettait à passer des soirées
arrivés tous les deux on avait cet
intérêt d'entreprendre et on passait nos
soirées à faire des business des
business plans qui nous rend des
millionnaires au bout de quelques mois
sur le papier c'était beau mais en fait
même si tu es complètement taré c'était
faire
lui au moins on rêvait de plus tard et
qu'on allait s'amuser donc rêver 1 pour
prendre la petite la petite aventure
donc le moment de dépression etc avec
tomasz mis d'accord à les ancrer un truc
lui il était dans le développement
informatique 800 tech
moi j'étais dans la côte est ingénieur
bâtiment donc béton et là on s'est dit
ok avec nos deux compétences est ce
qu'on peut faire un truc ensemble
donc tu mets un tech et un bétonneur bon
bah pourquoi pas faire une application
dans le béton là il m'a posé une
question que s'il ya des entrepreneurs
dans la salle vous pouvez vous tous vous
poser la question il m'a posé la
question
ou est-ce que tu utilises du excellent
dans ton boulot ou est-ce que tu
utilises microsoft excel et où tu fais
de la saisie avec des chiffres dedans je
fais tout le temps savoir plus béton ses
fins dans le bâtiment par dont on
utilise les méthodes un peu archaïque
ça y est il ya presque plus de fax on
met on utilise le mail les fichiers
excel et le papier et là je me suis dit
ok ou est-ce que je perds du temps bas
dans les acsel ça va être dans la
gestion de budget le chiffrage de
bâtiments etc
on gère des millions d'euros après que
des cellules excellent on fait des
soustractions est en fait à partir de là
on s'est dit ok ou est-ce que tu passe
le plus de temps 70% tu le passes ou est
en fait me suis rendu compte que je le
passais en tant que maître d'ouvragé sur
mes appels d'offres sur mes
consultations d'entreprises sur le choix
des boîtes sur la vérification entre mes
chiffres âge mais budget sigean dans le
budget qu'elle les entreprises ont
choisi etc
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
c'est des trucs super chiant super
lourds qui sont ultra important mais qui
demande aucune valeur ajoutée
donc quand tu fais six ans d'études tu
fais ingénieurs etc pour faire de la
saisie c'était un peu frustrant
donc nous on a décidé de monter une
start up puis s'appelle un os pour appel
d'offres simplifié et on avait monté
cette boîte en étant au niveau le plus
bas quand on démarre on connait rien la
start up on sait pas ce que c'est au
juste le nom on démarre à nîmes donc en
province dans le sud de la france
on n'a pas un réseau de sartre peur les
incubateurs on sait pas ce que c'est et
on s'est dit trois règles on s'est fait
une promesse avec thomas on s'est fait
un pacte moral on est tenu trois
promesses
la première si on bosse ensemble qu'on
apprenne à prendre la 2ème promesses
qu'on s'est donné ça va
être à la persévérance si toi tu homme
si toi alex tu persévère dans chaque
décision dans chaque problème que tu as
et que tu veux aller au bout
en fonction de chaque problème de turin
et ben tu vas aller jusqu'au bout et si
on est deux associés à persévérer dans
notre mode de vie dans notre business
alors là on va tout démonter et la
troisième promesses qu'on s'est donné
c'est encore apprendre pourquoi
apprendre j'insiste vraiment sûrement
apprendre ça va être apprendre des
autres à prendre sur soi apprendre des
erreurs des autres apprend des échecs
apprend des réussites des autres c'est
de comprendre en fait tous les
raccourcis qu'on peut avoir pour aller
d'un point a donc au début de 2010 est
on est en mode bébé à un point b 2020
notre boîte doit être à l'international
entre démarrer un projet est allé à
l'international il ya un chemin qui est
plus ou moins houleux il ya des
raccourcis on peut faire la pirouette
comme ça on a tous fait des intégrales
et c'est enfin s'amène au même niveau
par contre on va galérer on va monter on
va galérer
donc comment faire un truc à peu près
les nerfs le truc pour faire un truc à
peu près linéaire ce fait beaucoup de
trucs c'est apprendre
on a lu des bouquins on a rencontré des
gens on allait sur youtube on s'est
formé on allait à plein de conférences
etc et ça l'apprentissage les plus
importants j'y pense quand on a commencé
à rentrer dans ce mode là on a même
investi personnellement 16000 euros de
formation seize mille euros la plupart
de mes potes investi dans une voiture
investi dans une maison investi dans des
fringues je passe est vraiment un
investissement investis dans des restos
des vacances nous on a pris notre petit
pactole qu'on avait cumulé depuis trois
quatre ans on a investi sa dent du
coaching
j'ai rencontré un mec qui est
extraordinaire c'est l'avis de la roche
ce mec là on a entendu parler en
rencontrant des patrons et nous a permis
de faire en un an et demi une formation
qui nous a permis de faire du
développement personnel de comprendre
comment communiquer avec les gens
comment communique entre associés ce qui
est le plus important
et comment communique avec nos clients
et encore mieux comment on communique
avec nos investisseurs
donc là dessus on a démarré et ensuite
on a créé la boîte on avait besoin d'un
levé 1 million d'euros et c'est là où
l'on rend dans le sujet de son fameux
millions d'euros on était tellement
focus là dessus que en deux mois on
avait levé 1 million de
comment on l'a fait on l'a fait avec de
la persévérance
vous connaissez tous harry potter
j'imagine est ce que vous connaissez
l'histoire de jk rowling son auteur son
histoire elle est géniale à
l'extraordinaire elle a commencé à
écrire un bouquin est ensuite allé voir
un éditeur
le premier éditeur lui a dit non c'est
et rue de sourcier ça m'intéresse pas ça
va marcher c'est c'est has been etc elle
est allée voir un deuxième éditeur qui
lui a dit la même chose
elle est allée voir un troisième éditeur
qui lui a dit non mais à la limite tu
fais des trucs pour enfant de trois ans
ça peut passer
et en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la plupart d'entre nous je pense
même 110% de la salle au bout de trois
refus quand on est écrivain vous y
accueille cependant en fait elle est
allée voir un 4ème éditeur un cinquième
éditeurs dix éditeurs d'hier fut un 11e
12e 13e et le 14e a dit oui faut y aller
quand même faut y croire et en fait elle
elle croyait à ses rêves elle est allée
jusqu'au bout et c'est ça qui nous a
poussés quand on a levé notre milieu on
allait voir 150 business angels au début
on n'avait rien on avait un vieux
logiciel qu'on avait co dès le week-end
ça marchait pas s'appliquer dans tous
les sens on avait un powerpoint qui
disait quand tu cliquera la safra ça
quand tu cliquera la safra ça et quand
tu cliquera la safra ça c'est notre seul
moyen de lever des fonds pour embaucher
nos premières équipes et on l'a fait je
vous ai parlé de trois claques la
troisième
vous allez me dire mais qu'est ce que tu
as raconté bonta à plus ou moins réussis
tout ça en fait la troisième claque ça a
été les le regard des autres le regard
de mes proches de mes amis les anciens
collègues au début qu'on compte créer la
boîte je passais pour un fou on me
disait mais [ __ ] mais alex d'emprunt
quitter un cdi d'un emploi stable un
salaire stable et une augmentation
toutes les années tu as une mutuelle et
une voiture de fonction tu peux partir
le week end sans payer l'essence mais
c'est génial et c'est génial
en vrai c'est cool ça cool mais en fait
je me suis dit non c'est plus fort que
moi faut vraiment qu'ils entreprennent
et après c'est la troisième place
justement c'est une amie une ancienne
collègue à moi tient soit au moins qu'on
se retournant une soirée un peu importe
et là elle me dit alex tu as de la
chance alex tu as de la chance parce tu
as trouvé ta voix tu as trouvé ton truc
tu t'éclates ça se vois t'as pas la même
gueule que quand tu étais salariés août
était au fond du trou
là je te vois bon état des cernes ok
mais par contre
là tu es là je me suis dit [ __ ] au
début c'est cool ouais j'ai un peu de
chance mais après quand c'est ton frère
tu te dis ça quand c'est ta famille qui
disent la caisse était cousin qui te dit
ça là ça commence à faire mal
ça fait mal pourquoi est ce que tu te
rends compte qu'en fait il sort que je
vous ai raconté
elle concerne pas que moi elle concerne
des dizaines des centaines voire des
milliers de personnes des millions et
des milliards j'en sais rien en fait il
ya beaucoup trop de personnes qui ont eu
des rêves gamin jusqu'à 20 ans et
ensuite qu'ils ont oublié ses rêves
est-ce que je vous faire passer comme
message aujourd'hui pour ça qu'il me
suis levé le matin que j'ai bossé cette
aide c'est de vous faire passer le
message que vivre ses rêves c'est la
chose la plus importante est d'être
monsieur chanceux ça ne marche pas c'est
pas ça l'a fait on est plein de gens à
se dire tiens plus tard je ferai ça plus
tard je ferai ça est en fait j'avais
peur
à 26 ans peuvent rendre compte que à 46
ans vingt ans après ok j'avais eu mes
rêves les avait noté etc
mais à 46 ans de le dire [ __ ] j'ai
fait ces trois claques
je les rappelle la première c'est de
m'en rends compte que je me suis oublier
la deuxième c'est de me rendre compte
que j'ai oublié mes rêves est la
troisième claque c'est de me dire [ __ ]
les gens me voient comme un chanceux
alors juste en train de réaliser mes
rêves
aujourd'hui je sais pas à quel niveau
vous en êtes si vous avez en tout vingt
ans pensez à noter vos rêves nos télés
écrivez-vous une lettre à relire à 25
ans à 30 ans à 45 ans écrivez vous pour
plus tard ça part un peu taré mais
faites-le
franchement ça aide si vous avez plus de
20 ans et vous fait un point sur votre
vie prenez ce temps là accepter le fait
que ok vous n'avez pas fait tous les
rêves que vous vouliez par contre
accepté le fait qu'il faut faire quelque
chose à accepter le fait de changer
votre vie de t'améliorer votre vie et si
je doit rebondir sur le phénomène de
chance si j'ai qu'une chance sur
laquelle j'ai pu compter jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est la chance que je me
suis donné à moi la chance que je me
suis né pour justement prendre
conscience que tout allait mal pour
prendre conscience qu'il fallait que je
fasse quelque chose et pour prendre
conscience qu'il fallait que je me
rappelle de mes rêves la chance que j'ai
eue c'est de me rendre compte qu'il
fallait vraiment que j'agisse la chance
que j'aille poursuivre elle mérite donc
je vous souhaite à tous et à tout ce
qu'une seule chose ce soir
ces données vous cette chance merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]